entonces la bienvenida a Jorge Hurtado
de la redacción de economía de France 24
para conversar sobre la óptica económica
de lo que ha significado este conflicto
para las economías del mundo Jorge muy
buenas noches Gracias por acompañarnos
vamos a analizar Entonces el impacto que
ha tenido la Guerra de Ucrania en
nuestra región en América Latina bueno y
puntos positivos y negativos en esta
situación desde antes de la invasión
hace un año el mundo ya vivía los
efectos de las interrupciones en la
cadena de suministro esto sumado a la
guerra provocó un Boom en los precios de
las materias primas beneficiando
indirectamente a muchos países
exportadores de la región la
incertidumbre que provocó la Guerra en
Europa del este generó las subidas de
los precios internacionales incluidos el
petróleo el gas los fertilizantes y los
alimentos este gráfico por ejemplo
muestra como Durante los primeros meses
del conflicto la región pasó de la
crisis a la oportunidad ya que América
Latina es una región tradicionalmente
proveedora de estos bienes un análisis
de la cepal mostró Como algunos
commodities exportados por América
Latina como el carbón triplicó su del
2018 mientras que los fertilizantes
orgánicos llegaron a casi cuadriplicar
su valor de 2018 a abril del año 2022
otras materias primas que experimentaron
por supuesto su vida significativas
fueron el aceite de girasol el gas
natural y el aceite de Palma aunque los
precios se fueron moderando a medida que
el conflicto se extendió Jorge también
saludo de mi parte para ustedes y Quiero
preguntarle cómo benefició esta guerra a
América Latina indirectamente por el
conflicto ya usted nos contó los
impactos Sí bueno el aumento de los
precios de los alimentos en los mercados
mundiales hizo que las exportaciones
agropecuarias brasileñas por ejemplo
crecieran un 36% el año pasado hasta los
75 mil millones de dólares en Argentina
los principales complejos agropecuarios
se incrementaron los ingresos son 8,5%
hasta los 46 mil millones de dólares por
la subida de los precios en los mercados
internacionales que supuso la guerra
Pero además de esto de las oportunidades
en el sector agropecuario algunos países
aprovecharon la coyuntura para
incrementar sus exportaciones de carbón
y petróleo un ejemplo es Perú cuyas
ventas de gas natural licuado y petróleo
se elevaron un
57,9% en 2022 también Brasil y Colombia
aumentaron las exportaciones de petróleo
respecto a esto hay comentarios de parte
de los analistas escuchemos
hay que recordar que la recaudación
tributaria generada por todo el sector
minero y petrolero principalmente es un
dato muy importante en esta recaudación
brasileña y alcanzó niveles elevados de
casi el 2,6% del pib
algo muy por encima de nuestra serie
histórica que también ayudó que la
economía brasileña crezca más y que el
gobierno pueda gastar más también fue un
momento muy difícil para todos los
países pero en términos relativos Brasil
se vio beneficiado
fue beneficiado Jorge pero la región de
América Latina en cierta forma podemos
decir que se libró del impacto de la
guerra si lo comparamos con otros países
alrededor del mundo aunque no todo fue
tan positivo cuáles fueron esos puntos
complicados bueno según el fondo
monetario internacional tras un año de
guerra las economías de América Latina
resistieron bien pese a estos shocks
derivados de la invasión en 2022 la
economía de la región se expandió casi
4% el empleo repuntó con fuerza y el
sector de los servicios Se recuperó del
daño causado durante la pandemia la
inflación está comenzando a ceder en la
mayoría de países gracias a las subidas
de los tipos de interés que llevan a
cabo los bancos centrales y al descenso
también de los precios mundiales de los
alimentos y la energía pero la inflación
subyacente la que excluye si la energía
por ser más volátiles se mantiene en un
nivel de alrededor del 8% en Brasil
México y chile incluso algo más alto en
Colombia pero el fmi adelanta que 2023
podría ser un año difícil para América
Latina el crecimiento apunta a decrecer
rumbo al 2% en un contexto de tasas de
interés más altas y por supuesto de
precios más bajos de las materias primas
ya es un hecho que la creación de empleo
el gasto de consumo en bienes y
servicios están cayendo y la confianza
de los consumidores y las empresas está
debilitándose el crecimiento de la
región seguirá el ritmo de Estados
Unidos y también de la zona del euro que
son importantes socios comerciales Y
entonces cómo se puede ver el aumento de
los precios en la región Bueno voy a
darles un caso concreto México allí
justo cuando se cumple un año de la
invasión el precio del kilo de la
tortilla subió 12,5% para quedar en un
precio de 22,76 pesos mexicanos en las
tortillerías Durante este año de guerra
el precio de este elemento que es
esencial para la dieta mexicana un 20%
esto por el incremento en los precios de
la harina de maíz el costo de la factura
eléctrica el gas e incluso el transporte
según los analistas los precios seguirán
altos en 2023 pese a los esfuerzos del
gobierno mexicano para frenar esta alza
Jorge y otro factor importante aquí
fueron los fertilizantes Porque muchos
de ellos son producidos justamente en
Rusia y también en el este de Ucrania
que es la zona que está en conflicto en
disputa por estos dos países esto
claramente impactó la industria agrícola
de la región como bueno que los precios
bajaron desde su pico de marzo pasado en
parte es por la debilidad de la demanda
ya que los agricultores disminuyeron las
aplicaciones de fertilizantes en los
campos por problemas de disponibilidad
algunos países afectados por el descenso
de importaciones de fertilizantes son
Honduras Nicaragua y Perú el sector
tiene problemas de oferta como la
escasez de producción en Europa las
interrupciones debidas a las sanciones a
Rusia y belarrus y las restricciones
comerciales también que se están
aplicando a China un dato importante es
que estas sanciones comerciales tienen
excepciones para los sectores
alimentarios y de fertilizante con el
fin de evitar efectos adversos en la
seguridad alimentaria mundial Pero estas
excepciones han permitido a Rusia seguir
importando fertilizantes Jorge hoy más
que nunca un agradecimiento a ustedes
por estar con nosotros y traernos toda
el resumen de cómo se ha visto afectado
el mundo de América Latina gracias a
este año de la guerra te deseo a usted
una feliz noche y Santiago pues se llega
el momento ahora de darle la bienvenida
a nuestra siguiente invitada de esta
noche Margarita cada